all right just going to be a good app
the first time you've been in the room
together in six weeks baby i i miss you
i love you i know we have it's a
celebration of life today kane tanaka we
talk all about kane tanaka on this
episode rest in peace if you don't know
our mascot kane tanaka passed on april
25th and uh we celebrate her life in
this world we tell stories about kane
yes
things that people don't know behind the
scenes stuff about kane tanaka pics we
have that kane tanaka only showed us
that's true yes and we asked you for
your king tanaka stories so it's gonna
be a lot of fun we talk a lot of other
stuff too a lot of other stuff also this
cane tanaka merch yes we have it out
it's out until right now as is all of
our merch kane tanaka versus everybody
it's on uh you can get it on
the store and then you get it in the
store you can probably get it at christy
comedy.com but for sure we know it's at
salvolcanocomedy.com
for the other link it's gonna come out
but kane tanaka merch out limited run
limited run a portion of the proceeds
will go to a foundation in japan to help
out the japanese people who can't tanaka
gave birth we just we we just had this
idea and so we're going to research the
uh yes the torsion is going to go to
charity and kane tanaka will be watching
in heaven on april 29th she will be
watching me at the wind creek event
center in bethlehem pennsylvania you can
to christy comedy.com also may 5th just
added at the peppermint lounge in los
angeles and may 24th at the vulcan gas
company in austin texas and phoenix
arizona may 26 christy comedy.com for
ticky wickies kane tanaka's watching it
all kingdoms
and i am playing vegas at the verge at
the theater at the virgin hotel and that
uh it's on pre-sale right this second
promo code god bless one word and
tomorrow morning which is april 28th
friday it is on sale to the general
public so vegas may 14th basically sold
out at the beacon but they are releasing
the whole town so you can still get good
tickets right now new york city may 14th
san diego may 21st at the el cajon
theater yes and then the wilton theater
in los angeles on may 22nd all those
tickets are on sale right now and next
week i'm announcing about 15 to 20 new
cities it's amazing i'm going to be
watching from heaven
savilecanoncomedy.com patreon coming
soon
[Music]
how do
i
say goodbye
to what we had
the good times that made us laugh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but forever
oh it's so hard
to say goodbye
to caine
tanaka hey babe hey babe how you doing
oh it's been a rough couple of days i've
been pouring out green tea like nobody's
business you don't understand what i've
been doing yes i mean kane tanaka uh is
in heaven now she died at 1 0019 i mean
119
years old um
and i swear to god i saw the news off of
your tweet yeah and i literally took a
knee yeah i i felt look
she's she's if we have if we have if we
have
a mascots on this show which i feel like
we do she's got to be she's got to be at
the top of the list she's at the top of
the list now this is kane tanaka in 1931
as a 80 year old woman um
um she was born prematurely on january
2nd 1903. well she made up for that on
the back
on the back end wait she was even born
pretty much she was even older she was
older than she would be yeah she was
born at the regular time she's kane
tanaka was the oldest living person
shout out kane um and she's held that
honor for nearly three years she's a
she's a fighting champ yeah now i just
want to say i just want to make it clear
because a lot of people have speculated
that the week we took off of hey babe
is
coincides with the week kane tanaka died
and i want to say publicly uh through my
attorney that we did not have anything
to do with the deputy tonight we had
nothing we refused to believe that we
had anything we had nothing to do with
it i i i mean
could us not
being together one week have broken a
spirit i mean at that age i had a spirit
has a lot to do with it yes but i'm i'm
still of the firm believer that she has
no idea who we are i don't i see
i think word got back i personally think
i personally think
somebody told kane
that there are two
comedians uh in the united states who
she listen she may or may not like our
country i don't know she may or may not
she may or may not i don't know i don't
know she was alive when some things went
down yeah she was there she was alive
when all things went down when all
things went down yeah yeah yeah she was
around when they got butter or something
like that i think she was i think yeah
they created they created butter cane
tanaka may have created butter i don't
know yeah but kane tanaka i could see if
she wants to hold a gripe against us i
could see because we did do some some
things to our country in the 40s what
could you can google we didn't
i no no i did not no 1940s no i was
in 1945 i was swimming around in my
father's four-month-old nut sack right
my father
what a visual yeah
yeah what was your guys favorite memory
of kane anything for her eulogy here uh
for kane first time i was out at a bar
with kane right yeah i would say this no
one time i was at a bar with kane yeah
and we just we we were just there it was
like let's catch up it was like a
neighborhood spot and we're drinking
we're drinking hot cane like so whiskey
drinking and it's like another bee
another pint another drink not a pint
whatever and then you know we're just
having a good time and then all of a
sudden somebody wants us not some static
somebody somebody had come up behind us
in the bar and like went right in
between our stools okay and just like
budged in there and just like
accidentally like elbowed kane yeah when
he came in yeah and he was like he was
drunk you know and uh with elbow kane no
accident when was this
at this point now i mean maybe 12 years
ago so she was 107 years old yeah
this is when she was still out and about
what i was gonna say she was still she
was young healthy yeah yeah yeah so so
kane's like oh you know hit her in the
lip a little bit and she was like oh
take it easy and the guy's like i don't
need to take it easy yeah i can't say
look look we just came here to hang out
i mean yeah just here watching the nhl
playoffs right yeah and then she did she
loved it and then and then the guy was
like i'll do whatever i'll do whatever i
want and he walked away and when he
walked away
he was like [ __ ] under his breath she
heard it and then she was like what did
i ever take this no she takes her mug
her frosted beer mug she slams it down
on the bar she splits open she's holding
the handle still but now she has it like
almost like a weapon like a weapon she
turns around she goes right up to him
she grabs him by the collar she puts it
right under her throat and she's like
you don't want to see what i could do to
you right now kane said to him
wow and the guy was like all right i
don't want to troll but then all his
boys get up
all right and now it's like all right
how much damage she can can she do with
the mug sure against six other guys and
i'm only one guy and at that point i
wasn't doing jiu jitsu right so
she starts swinging it around
and someone gets out of her hand they
wrestle her down someone starts beating
her
on the floor but then she uh she kneed
him in the balls that guy falls over she
gets up she jumps off the table flying
knee to the guy's face oh my gosh she
ends up wiping them all out i held one
guy down the whole time but she took
care of five wow that's what came
through and that's what kane did and
that was that was on staten island yeah
that was at uh coaches at coaches on si
yeah yeah she loved kane tanaka loved
staten island yeah um she loved uh
you know
i can remember
a time we were on the ferry i was on the
ferry with with kane yeah and um this
was
this was jesus because i was i think it
was me my mom and kane and this was the
late 90s so she was about 94 years old
in about 1998
and um we were on the ferry and my
mother single mom she wanted you know uh
ninety she was here was this this was
1998. so she was that she was still
playing lacrosse at that time yeah yeah
yeah and she and my mom
my mother um
you know single mom and was looking like
they were actually going actually
i and this happened before my mom would
bring a lot of times my dad couldn't
couldn't watch me but my mom wanted to
live her life my mom had me when she was
very young and i understand that and my
mom and kane tanaka together we're going
to like a singles meet up like a like a
singles mixture so she was kane was her
husband had died 25 years and her
husband yeah her husband had died in the
70s yeah at the age of 98. yeah and and
he until my mom and cain were going
my mom and kane were going to a singles
mixer
and i remember being a kid
and it was great uh kane bought me a
pretzel um she showed me how to eat a
pretzel with chopsticks which was
beautiful thank you never even heard of
it never even heard that's what kane did
she brought her culture and made it okay
next thing you know
they go out first of all they start
drinking
and yeah because you know kane like to
drink it's going to be at night if she's
on she's on her [ __ ] if kane's on her
[ __ ] yeah it's going to be a night
[ __ ] yeah at that time what had just
come out the movie titanic my mother is
holding cane up like rose from titanic
my mother was making believe she was
leonardo dicaprio and kane was rose and
cain actually was older than rose at
that time right and she's kane was older
than the titanic
yeah and she's holding her up yeah
holding her up
and it's you know my my i'm watching
this thing and it's like crazy i'm like
you do that with kane because she was so
light she was so light yeah next thing
you know kane turns around to my mother
and says that's the best i felt
in the last 60 years of my life that's
the best i felt what are we going to the
singles mixer you and i should be
together kisses my mother right on the
mouth you never told me this section
yeah my mother and kane tanaka
maintained a lesbian relationship for
upwards of five years until my mother
met gary carry this thing
that's unbelievable because i was just
about to tell you something the way that
i found out that santa wasn't real was
through kane because get this so we used
to we used to open presents in the
morning sure right when i was little we
did one with the uh at new year's eve at
christmas eve right and then the rest of
my family was the morning so you guys
shall hold his witnesses no okay but we
dabbled yeah yeah but but then we said
this wasn't for us so so so so one
morning like little did i know that my
dad used to be the one that dressed up
as saying i learned this later in life
okay so my dad actually he's doing a
double at work they call him in on
christmas morning right now we have
nobody to be saying my mom can't dress
up as santa not because she didn't have
no adult there where's my mother and
also gender norms weren't as accepted as
they were now at that point there
couldn't be a female santa but now there
can be a female santa now that can
actually who says
santa has a gender now who says santa
has a race really nothing i think it
could be anybody
santa could be a transgender korean i
know that now but but at the day of when
i looked behind like the beard and the
hair and everything i saw i recognized
kane's face she's just doing my mom a
favor she dresses up as santa moss for
me and my sister she comes down does all
the gifts and every day and i'm thinking
i'm young i'm young but i remember
thinking like
it doesn't look like the old white guy
that i know
and so i got built up the nerve after
she was done eating the fortune cookies
we left yes and i was wondering why we
left fortunes because that's chinese
because that doesn't make any sense
right no because it doesn't it wouldn't
even play to that but i think that we
had no cookies left and we had left over
from kane was just a sweet woman she
would do that she would understand at
that point like this and they're trying
their best to take what kane did it's
what kane did she never was like oh
that's actually not my culture she just
ate the fortune cookie right and and i
just at the end before she left i was
like
is there something going on here i had
built up the nerve to do that and then
kane just pulled she pulled her white
beard down yeah and she was like it's me
it's kane and i was like oh my god she's
like look i was like where's santa and
she's like
sit down
and so we sat on the floor across our
legs no shoes that's what it is and then
she was like i thought i wasn't like
really
santa the idea santa existed a long time
ago but the idea of him now is just
carried on
through your parents and uh and she
explained the whole thing to me and i
got to be honest i would have been
devastated right if i found that another
way but cain had a way
of talking to you yes and it almost was
comforting that i found out through her
and it's just like kane did it's just
what came out you guys think we should
petition to make april 25th cain tanaka
day i do think we should i i i think
about
making april 25th came to knock a day
and i think we make it only kane tanaka
day on staten island and i think that
baseball team right there the staten
island ferry hawk shout out i will be
there may 3rd if you'd like to come
shout out yes shout out to gary perrone
and everybody at the ferry hawk all
ticket proceeds to the game on may 3rd
which is coincidentally the same day my
netflix special especially where she
drops all tickets to the may third game
uh the staten island fairy hawks i will
be there go to uh the staten island
hospital uh cancer children's cancer
research so go support that as kane
tanaka would have um
this is in a few days it's been a few
days right yes this is coming out
thursday's thursday yeah it's coming out
in two days yeah yeah so it's a few days
in a few days your special comes out
especially on netflix comes out and kane
tanaka and i do think april 25th
should be kane tanaka day only on the
only in the borough of staten island i
think which is where
i also have been in contact with her
family there is a chance some of her
ashes might be scattered along the
staten island ferry which was her
favorite boat to ride also the first
place she kissed my mother who she did
wind up saying was the love of her life
at the end of her life right and how
what kane got to what age 119.
yes
119 which is the um
the uh the uh grammar school that was in
my neighborhood that um
some of the uh children went to
she married her husband at 19 years old
she married a there's a while there's a
lot of symbolism
100 years ago she married a husband
wow 19 19 22. they never met before they
married either wow wow let's give a
little let's let's let's give the honest
a little bit let's read a little bit
about kane yeah because they're they're
you know also there also could be some
people who have gotten on to hey babe uh
have gotten out to habib in the last few
weeks and sal and i haven't done an
episode together in about five or six
weeks we've had a lot of replacements
want to give shout out to joe deroser
shout out to tt jerry shout out to uh
brian quinn shout out to all the people
who filled in and helped sal and i
through these times because the truth is
is why we didn't
get together for the last few few weeks
it's because we knew that cain was dying
and we were in japan
it's not our place to say to everybody
it was not a place to say it wasn't our
place we were asked by the family to
keep a secret and we did so we knew kane
was dying and we were in japan we had uh
we were the tanakas we were with the
tanakas um and um
and we were having fun not having fun we
were celebrating her life yeah um as she
slowly died at 119. if she wanted to go
out with a bang so we and we kind of as
a gift to her and as a memory of her we
said we're not going to do the pot we
won't be in the same room until she
passes over
into the japanese heaven which she has
she is now firmly in japanese heaven
yeah um so she was you know and and so
you know just to honor her we want to
read about
you know who kane tanaka is was and
always will be yeah okay january 1922
cold cold winter day in japan she
married her husband hideo tanaka whom
she hadn't met before their wedding day
the organization said now the family did
verify that they hadn't met before the
wedding day um
so i guess you know that's just how it
was back then when i get a judge and
leave it to kane to make that work right
because that wouldn't fly today she was
just built differently kane it's what
kane did yeah she was like 90 day fiance
how about 90-year fiance yeah yeah yeah
they went on to have four biological
children and adopted a fifth that's
unbelievable that's unbelievable while
hideo served in the second sino-japanese
war tanaka helped run their family
business which involved making sticky
rice udon noodles and desserts she knew
that we love sweets yeah and she did
that for us her first son nobu no
relation to nobu malibu later fought in
world war ii and was held captive by the
soviet union until 1947 wow he got held
by the russians and still to this day
even though uh he's a great guy we were
just with him we would just squirt them
no boo he was a great guy they don't
even have any remorse towards the
russians even with what's going on i
mean they stand with ukraine
yeah but they were they were like you
know kane tanaka said listen vladimir
putin she goes what is he five or six
years old he's just a kid you're right
you know you can't judge him yeah he's
just a baby black yeah and she she was a
voice of reason she was often a voice of
reason now what do you guys think about
the conspiracy that the second oldest
woman poisoned kane tanaka because
they're that's what we're getting to the
world's new oldest living person now is
sister andre not eric andre sister
a french nun who is 118 years and 73 73
days old so significantly younger than
kane yeah um sister andre also holds the
distinction of being the oldest survivor
of covent 19.
well i mean that news didn't get out
yeah that would have i mean she was 118
and she survived covered she survived
that bucks the that bucks the statistics
that we've got yeah which is interesting
too even kovan 19 more 19 surrounding
kane tanaka i think she wanted to live
through that and show wow i can beat
anything including this little pandemic
yeah that you've cause she did not die
of cold no she did not tanaka
see like sister andre honestly now she
looks like she's in kindergarten to me
yeah she looks youthful she must
moisturize yeah she probably uh has a
lot of um
uh sheet superfoods i'm sure yeah
there's a lot of superfoods a lot of uh
what's the word i'm looking for the uh
anti uh speaking of superfoods would you
like an energy ball from north side
coffee i don't mind if i do
what's it an energy ball oh i don't know
the girl just said she said would you
like our energy balls there from
yesterday i'll give them to you for half
price i said sure why the hell not i'll
eat an energy ball yeah there's a half
the energy in it it's still full energy
shout out north side coffee
very good
i mean i taste peanut butter
it's garbanzo face chalk you have an
allergy
sorry to the people who hate chewing
um into the pod and you're welcome to
the people who are masturbating to the
chewing center
msfr what's it called ms13 what do we do
msrp
yeah something like that right
asmr am sr a t it's one of these things
where i could have just texted kane and
had the answer and now we can't um
um
it was about the time i was at mike
i was at um
what i'm wearing roback i told you did i
not tell you before i know the best
shirt i've ever had in my life and i
truthfully mean that yeah i got some the
the the material oh my god lightweight
but it fits right i love the way it
looks it's all performance the cuts
really good it's one of these shirts
where i feel like i can wear this out to
like
look nice hang out work out whenever
yeah performance hoodies performance
polos performance q zips they also sent
me some q-zips i
actually went on the site and bought
like
a lot of merch for a lot of shirts with
them and i used the code vape yeah i
really did yeah and because i love
rollback so much um
and it's been gaining a lot of traction
and it's it's getting bigger and i got
to be honest with you man i love i love
it it's it's really like truthfully like
they sent me some pants too that i love
but this is my favorite shirt like and
it's so light i feel like i could wear
this in the summer no i know i opened up
i was like wow this is really nice yeah
the pants are crazy too because they
have they could also feel like they're
dress pants and
it's not like they're like they have
like the tapered leg and the zipper and
everything it's like it was and then if
you look inside it had the inside the
pants has that like soft yeah it's
almost like basketball it's like a funny
dress inside yeah no i love it and right
now if you go to rollback.com rh
20
very generous to them 20 off your first
order to the end of this week when you
use the code babe b-a-b-e that's
r-h-o-b-a-c-k.com
20 off all polos q-zips hoodies and tees
with code babe b-a-b-e make sure to
check out their freshly restocked
hoodies and new masters gear just in
time for the spring nice
baby no i know you love doordash i used
it last night i am not joking at all i
use it all the time doordash is awesome
whatever you want to eat tonight you
want to have a favorite home-cooked meal
whatever but you don't want to go to the
store you go to doordash baby it's
what's exciting and new i use doordash i
would say truthfully i use doordash
15 times a week i'd say oh wow that's
more than me yeah
i use it a handful of times a week me
and pimp were hanging out yesterday i
adored theirs three times i got door
dash iced coffees then i do a dash lunch
and i
can get groceries now too i love things
like that and any restaurants that don't
have delivery you can get them to your
house it's crazy along with the
restaurants you love you can now get
groceries and other essential items
delivered with doordash get drinks
snacks and other household items in
under an hour with over 300 000 partners
you can support your neighborhood
go-to's or choose from your favorite
national restaurants like popeyes
chipotle boom and the cheesecake
and right now if you go it's a limited
time it's limited time you're going to
get 25 off and zero delivery fees on
their first order of 15 or more when you
download the door dash app and enter the
code hey babe
so just put in the code hey babe
h-e-y-b-a-b-e
25 off your first order with door dash
up to a 10 value and zero delivery fees
on that first order when you download
the doordarshan in the app store and
enter hey babe don't forget that's code
hey babe for 25 off your first order
with doordash subject to change terms
apply i was at a wedding okay with kane
that's your plus one
kane was there got it she was my plus
one she was there
it was a big to-do there was a big role
because
at the wedding the bride
found out that the husband might have
been cheating on him oh my god and it
was about to be mayhem there was 600
people at his wedding it was about to be
full on mayhem she was going to come out
and she was going to she was going to
confront him in front of all the guests
and kane was like i can't let this go
down right and kane got right in the
middle of it and it turns out like you
know that probably was like no i don't
care i heard that he's you know he's
sleeping with the guy you know from my
job and there's a whole table of people
from my job and they're murmuring about
they're looking at me i could tell blah
blah blah blah blah blah and kate's like
well who said that you know and she's
like oh the table like table ten so king
goes over to table ten and takes up with
everybody at table ten and she's like
you know the bride's over that's not
right you know so she's gonna come out
she's gonna run the whole wedding you
know all right this isn't the place your
time for this like you guys stop talking
about this at the wedding right all
right and then
they were like ah and then she just put
him and she was like is this true is
this true it turns out like they were
all just like it was all hot goss
got it and
and this was about to ruin this wedding
and it was just this one girl that was
instigating because she had a crush on
philip
the the groom the groom and so kane gets
her outside it was like jordan venetian
now at this point so we got passed
mostly did kane make the desserts
because she did her family the tanakas
make the desserts because remember they
made sticky rice udon noodles desserts
there was there was a sticky rice table
sticky rice um what do you call it like
a station that had to be that had to be
produced by tanaka treats yeah
tanaka treats
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so if you it
was a sticky rice station you get any
kind of stickers that you want and they
made them right they have to order
um
and kane gets her outside and she's like
look you know this has to stop you know
this is not what we do here you know you
can't you can't come between a union
like this right and the girl i guess
again alcohol is involved and the girl
pushes back at kane kane reaches behind
her i see her with a backhand she
reaches behind her she takes a
that was on the table the pie station
yeah and she just slips around just
slaps this girl in the face with a with
the pie with a pie bro good it was it
was humiliating enough for the girl to
just stand down yeah but she saved the
wedding kane and not not not one of
those 600 guests knew that she saved the
wedding and they didn't know it was
about to implode yeah that's just what
kane did that's just what kane did kane
was always there
kane tanaka was one of those people that
she wouldn't mind putting herself
in you know kind of an awkward situation
or harm's way to save a beautiful day
for someone else i mean let me tell you
about this time i saw her save a
chihuahua no true i was in the highway
right okay keynes we were going we were
on a walk whatever trial was in the
highway charlotte's whoever struggled
this is we don't know stumbles onto the
highway okay what was the bqe sentinel
expressway it was the si expressway when
she was here she goes i'm like oh my god
that dog and we look there's a truck on
the expressway coming toward this dog
kane runs out literally literally kicks
the dog out of the way
he had no time the dog was low king
kicks the dog out of the way he's a
light but dog
goes across like two or three lanes mack
truck
[ __ ] mack truck slams into kane can't go
swimmin
the front grill the mack truck just
slapped just literally
slammed into kane he had only hit the
brakes like like 10 feet early it was
full force slaps came kane's body goes
30 40 feet
sliding down the asphalt oh my god yeah
shoes came off everything the slippers
came off
and then other cars are slack
and then everyone just jams on the
brakes and she's like 40 feet down she
had slid across here so all her clothes
were ripped up everything was ripped up
and she just kind of got up and she was
she was shook you know she
took that hit and she saved that dog she
saved that dog she got hit with a mack
truck that nearly full speed cane
yeah and she got right back up she
landed on her feet yeah yeah walk back
and you guys continue your day she was a
survivor
i mean to survive for 119 years yeah i
mean you know she survived everything
kane she survived world war ii she
survived the mack truck she survived 911
she survived everything she survived i
mean all coved she survived anything
she was born in 1903 the year we
invented flight
yes that's what it said the wright
brothers invented the plane what was
kane tanaka's cause of death do we know
what actually
she because you know i hope it was just
natural causes yeah nobody you know
hangnail she wasn't murdered no that's a
different honor okay she's five cancer
and lift through two pandemics the
spanish flu and cove at 19.
yeah i know
she's unknown cause of death it might
have been a broken heart from hey babe
it might have been a broken heart from
your mother i do think cain tanaka died
of a broken heart i really do
do you guys do you guys think the fans
should chime in with their favorite cane
tanaka memory i do think that yeah guys
guys if you could just write to us uh in
the comments on one of our social
platforms and just share a cane story
what hashtag should they use
um i would say they should use r.i.p
yeah um i would say they should use um
uh
cancelled
k-a-n-e
c-e-l-l-e-d just to share because god
canceled her because god canceled her
cancelled okay that's what i did
sold
c-e-l-l-e-d okay kane sold kane soldier
instead of canned salt same way but
replaced candy cane
k-a-n-e s-c
k-a-n-e-c-e-l-l-e-d perfect and just
share just share
at least one kane story yeah which is
also the name of this episode is i think
it should be cainsult
[Laughter]
um i i think you know big daddy kane
took his name from her right from kane
to knockout yeah big daddy
yeah she's been she's been she's been
influencing people
she influenced the whole hip-hop
community you're not showing you guys
the woman up kane woman okay woman up
kane woman up kane that's because uh she
used to walk on hot coals really yeah
and and every time it was like a party
trick that she did yeah she would go to
like backstage in like hip-hop green
rooms or something they would just dump
the coals on the floor and she just like
she'd to step over them yeah and they'd
be like warming up okay
and he made the whole stone
kanye west has been rumored to take a
derivative of kane tanaka and make his
name kanye yeah
yeah yeah
he added a why yeah why which why we we
we know why we don't know no we know why
because she's she's she's influential
she's
you know
even kanye look look at her right there
let's scroll up a little bit look at her
she's cashing that check throwing up
deuces yeah
and i think you know with all this kane
tanaka look at her in the middle
tell me she's not part of the hip-hop
community no she's like with a skully
cap on yeah that's that's that's how she
might be that might you're telling me
she's not a haybay fan she's stressed
like homeless pimp
now i think that's uh i think that's
going to be nasa's new album cover yeah
kane tanaka and this you know it's a
good time to bring up too that we do
have the merch out
yes
we do have our merch finally hit i don't
know if we said this [ __ ] because you
haven't been around yeah right now you
can get it there's like five six items
you can get it right now by going on my
website savilecandlecounty.com and just
going in the store on the right
it's in a minute we'll have the proper
uh we'll have an actual standalone
website and it'll be linked off of
chris's and actually the roses because
we have the taste buds stuff too but it
is out right now we have hoodies we have
t-shirts we have stickers we have uh i
love
the unicorn one with the rainbow
shooting it's kind of funny it's all
great it's all out there right this
second it's all available and
we think
we think yeah are we doing the yeah
we're doing it yeah all right we're
gonna we're gonna put up a cane tanaka
is that what you tell me yeah we're
gonna do a kane tanaka versus everybody
limited edition run lemon edition run
fort kane we're gonna try to get a
portion of the proceeds to kane's family
um if if you have access to kane
tanaka's family please let us know she
changed all the contact information
in the last 15 years yeah i just hope i
genuinely hope and pray
that there wasn't a mut this isn't a
money thing and she wasn't murdered by a
member of her family because i was
getting that vibe that they were
don't you feel like everybody wanted
something
everybody wanted something yeah they
like everybody was trying to take a
piece of cane and i was like yeah we're
here like yeah celebrating her life and
you're talking to me about wills and all
the stuff she owned and yeah you know
and i was just like man it wasn't like
that it was when she hit guinness
when she a guinness people were like oh
maybe there's something i could i can
get from this right and then that's when
the the bloodsuckers came out and do you
remember this do you remember
one episode we started talking about
board apes and we were going to buy a
board ape and we ran it by kane and cain
said do not do that it ain't safe right
that angel was right just breaking news
today the board 8 yacht club instagram
account has been hacked and millions
worth of nfts have reportedly been
stolen so kane knew
that that was not safe and we almost
took
thousands of dollars and bought a board
told us not to and now
that thank you kane i don't know if
you're in heaven or not i i i mean this
is the one last thing she did for us
from beyond yes that's unbelievable i
don't even know this i know i just find
this out right now real time really real
time right now
whoa well but let me say this this is
breaking news from the watcher guru so
the board ape yacht club instrument
count has been hacked and millions of
worth of nfts have been reported stolen
allegedly allegedly
not confirmed 100 100 i can't believe i
didn't see that coming all right yeah oh
totally uh you know what how could you
i'm sorry what if you came to knock his
last words were
i hope they were
allegedly
could you imagine at her funeral right
now she pops out of the cage you thought
i was dead allegedly
she goes nothing kills kane yeah
she takes out an ak-40 is killing
everyone
she's tanaka strong tanaka strong
another one to
do all right should we do kane versus
everybody what do you can do not
converse everybody or tanaka strong i
like i like tanaka strong
does anybody like cainsult
[Laughter]
no i like tanaka strong too um
or maybe it's just kane tanaka
with a heart around it
not to go to kane to not converse
everybody because that's what's her life
it's kane we're having everybody when we
finish today's thing we're having a we
got to decide because we're going to put
it up right away all right so hopefully
if we do it by may 3rd you're going to
see it there'll be orders be able to get
taken 100
by the way this is the lamest heist of
all time the internet's ruined
everything even robbery i know i'm
afraid for my own actual like bank
accounts like in in in banks but here's
what i heard someone like breaks in and
just hits like like control delete and
then my life savings is gone but i heard
private banks private banks have so much
hardware and they've invested so much
money in securing like you know chase
you know of course they're gonna tell us
that but i no but i heard not bad i
heard i was watching the news and they
were saying that's not really what like
the us government is afraid of when it
comes to hacking when they say oh russia
could hack us or whatever it's not your
personal bank accounts that's not re
they said because there's so much
invested in the banks
of protecting it what what can be taken
they said is like crypto stuff um they
said they could take like you know like
like investment accounts they can take
but not your personal yeah but still
what about my investment accounts
yeah they could take them
no i'm scared of [ __ ] though yeah you
know you scared i mean i'm sure they've
all been hacked already oh wow i've
gotten data breach like mail mail i got
a data breach mail uh the other day that
my mom said was laying on the uh coffee
table at my house that i grew up in for
three months i was like that would have
been a nice info three months ago to
change a password yeah yeah yeah i mean
yeah we get hit with data breach at all
time but i'm just worried like what
happens if like and then they hit it and
then like it's like oh no we don't know
what you have you can't take your word
for it like it's gonna be it'll be a
world war
people will be in the streets rioting
well that's the thing is everybody gets
you know they're talking about russia
talked about oh they have a nuke that
can hit new york city and whatever
that's really i mean that can happen and
what are you gonna do but really i think
what the real panic is is yeah is them
like crashing everything we have in the
world is run on like a big databases run
like on on like that grid so it's like
if they crash that if they if they
knocked out the power in the whole
country i mean we'd be dead in two weeks
yeah right
i would start we'd have to start eating
each other i have no skills i don't have
any skills at all i have zero i could do
a podcast yeah
we could but we will have to run off a
battery and then i don't think we can no
one's going to be able to listen to it
transistors that's what i have to do
transistor radios transistor radio we
find a way i'd find a way i have a book
that's like how to survive if [ __ ] goes
down my friend got it for me because
i am so i don't know anything and i i've
always said like if anything ever goes
down i'm going to die immediately right
he got me a survival book i have that to
thumb through have you do do you know
where it is
uh
it's probably in the closet in that room
over there so right so if there was a
man
do you think i'd probably run out of the
house i'd be so scared around the house
i'd forget the book now what'd you guys
do in the blackout in new york back in
the day did you panic no i slept in my
car i remember why i because that was
the only place that had air conditioning
i still went so hot i still went to work
i bartended we just the whole place was
candlelit so my mother wow
so my mother uh you know
went through 911 whatever was
traumatized you know survived and
everything went through you know
couldn't go back to work for months and
months and months because of
psychological trauma she was down the
whole thing the very first day the very
first day she went back to work was the
day of the new york city blackout the
train stopped in the middle of the you
know train station all lights went
wow it was just like the very first day
that's crazy he's been back to work
since all right yeah
damn yeah but but i just wanted to go
back i you're afraid of russia but did
you see this thing that went viral about
them saying uh spies were out to get uh
putin and instead of having cell phone
sim cards they had copies of the sims
video game
yeah see this is the thing with russia
it was
yeah
they said they got the sim cards and
it's sims video games they thought they
got like the sim cards like the
ukrainian like missile base
yeah
russia appears to confuse the sims for
sim cards and possible stage
assassination
well that's like
i don't know what to say
we so you're saying that's
they found russian spies
it's a they're staging that somebody
who's out to get putin a nazi
and this is their fake evidence oh my
god
well dude did you see did you see that
the on the very day
that russia announced that they have
allegedly
a
allegedly
bomb that can hit new york and that
would be resistant to all our nuclear
air defenses the very day did you hear
that nor do i did i need to hear that
well they found out that on the very day
russia says that they also they also
what happened was is they discovered
that this um uh
russian convoy like one of their big
generals russian convoy couldn't figure
out how they kept
like they would thought they would go to
like a secret meeting place and it would
just be attacked they couldn't figure it
out what happened they had went like a
couple days before and like raided some
like ukrainian village and they took
some guys airpods and he was just
tracking their airpods telling ukrainian
government i know exactly where they are
because i'm tracking them on my app he
was tracking him on like his kid's phone
being like yeah they're exactly right
they're kidding then they would just
drop bombs on them and the russian
general's like how do they know no they
had their airpods but at the same time
they're like yeah we can hit new york
city i'm like can you you're being
tracked by my i can track you on my
phone that's unbelievable yeah and that
pisses me off you know why yeah i can't
get my [ __ ] airpods to work ever
dude it's unreal i know people i mean i
have problems here but yeah like i can't
get him to work and the ukraine is
winning the war with them but they won
the war with airpods i can't connect
them yeah they drop all the time yeah
i know dude well that's why you need
raycon headphones that's right promo
code hey babe um speaking of
uh this podcast sponsored by better help
better know what it is you know what it
is stress it's going to show up in all
kinds of ways in a world that's telling
you to do more and you got to do this
you got to do that it's all stress and
better help has helped me talking to
licensed licensed professionals that are
going to help me combat my mental health
it's all over zoom it's all
on the hush hush nobody has to know
anything about nothing and if you don't
think you're feeling stressed you are if
you have a headache if you grind your
teeth if your digestive system's off i'm
350 probably probably being because of
stress and i mean we're all we all share
the same stresses right yes we got bills
and we got relationships and we got work
and we got everything else and it's just
well listen sometimes you need a little
help and that's why better help is is
awesome and i'll tell you why because
it's customized online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy give
it a try and see if online therapy can
help lower your stress this podcast is
sponsored by better help and hey babe
listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
hey babe that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l
dot com slash hey babe
this app true bill yeah i've been seeing
commercials for it on tv first of all
this is a genius yeah he's making
chicago
true bill do you know what it is i do so
true bill what did it it solved the
problem that everybody had how many
times are you subscribed to something
and you just forget that you've been
paying for it and next thing you know
you get a month you get a bill at the
end of the month you're like why not
even use this or you don't think you
subscribe to something yeah you paid
once and then they subscribe auto
subscribe and now true bill is the app
that helps you identify and stop paying
for subscriptions you don't need to want
or simply forgot about on average people
save up to 720 per year with drupal
that's a flight you could take a flight
from freaking new york city to toronto
and you know every every company they
make it hard they ever try to cancel one
you go on the page i don't see where to
cancel some people make you write to
them you got to email you got to write
in writing you got to find a little fine
print it's hard to cancel true bill
makes it incredibly simple you just link
your accounts up and trouba will cancel
your unwanted subscriptions in a single
tap your true bill concierge yes is
there when you need them to cancel
unwanted descriptions so you don't even
have to right that's right don't false
it fall for subscription scam start
canceling today at truebill.com
hey babe go right now to truebill.com
hey babe it can save you thousands a
year that's truebill.com it's what it is
you know what happened was this is the
thing money talks because at first they
were saying all the newsletters were
like
but then the investors were like listen
he's gonna give up 45 billion dollars
you need to sell it wasn't like 40
percent higher or something like that
it's ridiculous 60 higher than what the
going rate was what do you think he's
going to do with twitter if you had to
get i know he keeps preaching about
uh
uh not censoring anything but i don't
know if that's
do you think kane tanaka died when she
saw that news she was like she was a
guest on twitter
she was a guest yeah you always see like
people like if trump wins i'm moving to
canada yeah or you know if this happens
i'm doing that she was like yo
if he almost gets twitter i'm peaceing
out i'll peace it out that's i've seen
all i need to see i don't know yeah i i
don't know what's gonna happen i mean
dude i just hope i just hope that you
know him owning twitter uh makes twitter
a less evil place um i don't know if it
will or it won't but i think elon musk i
think elon musk actually might go down
as like
i think he's more influential than jeff
bezos i think elon musk is he's our
he's like our shakespeare almost like i
think elon musk is going to be talked
about
for
hundreds
hundreds of years to come
elon musk is my genghis khan
is that good
yeah okay elon musk is my dad he's my
papa
well don't you feel like he could have a
scientology following what do you mean
yeah what's your take on elon musk
because in some ways i'm like all right
he's an innovator he's this he's that i
don't know much about it but then
there's such a backlash against him too
like he could remember that thing where
he could have solved
he said he said if if the government
could write him a plan uh and and and
write a specific plan about how they
could solve world hunger for six billion
dollars he would do it
and then they did it
i don't think anyone got back to him
they did i think they did really yeah
they did and then he didn't do it but
then he bought twitter for 50 billion
dollars you ever see that sam kinnison
bit about world hunger where he's like
um
he's like i gotta i gotta whatever it i
forgot how he gets into it but he's like
you he goes just move to where the food
is
he's like sand you can't eat sand i
don't know it's probably i don't know if
i was just in tulsa apparently that's
where he was born and that's where he's
tulsa that's where he's buried or
something sam kimberson i think it's one
of my favorite communities of all time
yeah
his father was a preacher
so was he yeah i haven't seen you we've
discovered in like six weeks yeah and
since then you've gotten a haircut i got
puerto rico you went to puerto rico i
got covered i got a haircut did you get
a haircut before and after covet after
wow this cove did it change something in
your mind and be like i need i need to
cut my hair now no we just finally
finished filming season nine which
started in 2019 so i could cut my hair
because i don't want it to be like in a
scene with long hair and then the scene
with short hair got it so
i was waiting i was over the hair a
while ago so the day you finished like
two days later yeah wow but it's funny
because we have one or two bits left
over right from this season that we end
up having we'll like hopefully apply to
next season because why waste them but
have long hair
so that would be like in one episode
i'll have short hair and then long hair
but it's like it's not like we shoot the
episodes in order we have to shoot them
on a card anyway so right it's not like
a you know big deal but well um i um
yeah dude i uh it was a shock but uh um
i like oh oh wow sorry no sal
rightfully so is being distracted by a
model with the world's biggest cheeks uh
uh leaves fans stunned that she took out
her cheek filler right is that what you
get out
i don't know or she put it in i think
she might have put it in let's see oh
yeah this woman looks she's she's gonna
body this morphe right she thinks that
that's normal her name is uh anastasia
pokemon anastasia pro procheroshuk has
continuously wowed fans with her huge
cheeks
yeah oh she's from kiev
used to have a slender face and curly
hair in her 20s before she spent an
initial 1500 pounds on fillers but you
guys they're seeing this pimpy on the
vid
her cheeks look like she she has two
tennis balls in her cheeks yeah it looks
um it looks insane do you think she
would go on a first date with someone
and say
that she's all natural oh my god she's
so she's she's so pretty and normal
looking without the cheekbones yeah
yeah where do you even get influence to
do this i don't even know people have
true mental health what what is in there
what is the cheek what is silicone i
wonder no it's soft i thought it would
be hard i don't know how do you make my
cheeks
it looks like someone just it looks like
tyson punched her in both eyes yeah
right bro speaking of tysons you see
tyson punching that guy in the face how
great is that i love that yeah see i
always i'll always be scared of tyson
yeah even now he's like oh he's mellowed
out he owns a weed company he don't do
that [ __ ] no more no but at any given
moment that you can just yeah f you up
yeah just beat the crap out of you oh i
didn't see this extended version
guys so much dick this guy thank you so
much for being so obnoxious um but you
know what oh the kids in a solo this is
jetblue mint by the way which i love i
love jeopardy i mean
this tool is in jetblue mint the mint
cocktail
um
is he talking to a friend yeah i guess
he's got a friend
this guy yeah it looks like he has cheek
fillers
is there any is there any audio here
there's nothing to see what he's saying
no it's just [ __ ] yeah
now who's the guy there his friend that
ran over to stop it yeah
that was like trying to block it no i
think that was the guy i think that was
who tyson was sitting next to i think
tyson is with somebody yeah i'm
surprised he's not more damaged
yeah that well because because he was
getting tyson was getting blocked is
this like afterward is he like mocking
it like like yeah
i think he probably wants to be like a
meme but i mean everybody hates this guy
because and this guy has been arrested a
bunch of times yeah
yeah this guy it's like an annoying just
an annoying drunk idiot you know
what a douchebag yeah is he pushing
pressing charges
he is he is
yeah
i mean
people hate him i mean he's he's very
very very hateable um
what can you do shout out mike tyson um
mike tyson wow
madonna looks insane yeah i'm scared of
madonna yeah madonna's seems out of
touch lately huh this is not good
madonna she's got she looks is that is
that is that is that a filter
no
no that's not a filter are you sure
no it looks real
that's my donna's real face it's like
making me sad was that her breasts out
right there yeah well there she posted a
bunch of raunchy photos of herself it
because the question becomes at what age
do you stop being like hypersexual
right yes she's trying to
how old is she's trying to set the
precedent
i don't know let's see how old she is
you know it's it is weird what we do to
people right people get older they try
to age gracefully you call them old you
call them out of touch you go 63. you
know
oh really yes that's not that's not that
old but then people are like like her
are like no i'm not gonna do that i'm
gonna stay fashionable i'm gonna stay in
the conversation and try to stay
relevant i'm gonna keep my sexuality and
then you [ __ ] on for that well the thing
is too i think what happens is in this
country or in this the west most of the
western world is we don't celebrate
aging we're like scared of it because we
want to like be alive forever when it's
like
you should celebrate i'm scared of it no
but but but like we should talk to i
want to do i want to mention this to you
by the way i would love to have somebody
who's like 90 years old or older on the
pod and just ask them questions because
they have all day bro the person
the 95 year old person sitting next to
you in the park that you think has
nothing to say will tell you things that
will blow your mind because what they've
seen and heard and we almost get they're
afraid of that they're the only direct
connection to the past like living
connection i i'll say this all the time
i would sit down from the bar when i'm
back in my bar days i'd rather sit down
with an 85 90 year old person than a
[ __ ] 15 you say that all the time
i've never heard you say that once i say
it
i i mean i'll i'll sell whoever will
listen
i really do i don't do that i would do
did you have an old old timer in the bar
that would have many like we talked
about marty that time that he passed
away at the goddamn bar oh that's right
yeah
and we just kept the middle uh high life
and roses on his seat with a candle for
like months well you i forgot were you
there when he died i have a picture of
that i'll send him something awesome i
have a picture of him marty's dead body
in the bar
no not a step
i wasn't i wasn't there when he actually
passed but i felt bad but he sat in the
same seat every every everything but
yeah i i mean come on well because like
even like my grandfather right like i
remember my grandfather passed away when
i was about 16 years old and i remember
like uh you know learning like i had
loved history since i was like 10. yeah
and i never thought so i had five six
years of the able-bodied grandfather who
fought against the nazis in world war ii
i never asked him one question about it
and it's like
i could he could have sat down and blew
my mind like what i was learning about
in history class he was like yeah i was
there yeah both of my grandfathers were
and my one of my grandfathers saw a lot
of combat and he told me a lot of
stories see that's a beautiful beautiful
thing that yeah because yeah because i
don't think we should like shy away from
aging i think it's like it's some
cultures they like will have older
people come and talk to the kids all the
time where we would be like i think we
look at an old person like that's going
to happen to me i don't want to know
about it you know let's drink coca-cola
let's like let's just do american stuff
let's shove hot dogs in our mouth you
know yeah yeah yeah i i i will say i do
have severe depression and anxiety about
aging right why severe
it's such a sad thing to process i don't
want to bring everybody down yeah it can
be you know you lose your faculties you
get older you some people lose their
memories they they you know they they
lose their friends one by one they see
all the family and friends go before
them and then little by little gets you
know they get they're getting older and
older and it's just people taking care
of them and then god forbid they gotta
go into a uh you know a home or whatever
like that then people are just visiting
them once in a while i just it's such a
weird dismount at the end of life don't
you think it's all set up for god's
punchline
but it needs to be a punchline death is
just the punchline
i don't know man i to me it doesn't look
that funny well let me ask you this let
me ask you this rather than you growing
old would you like me to shoot you
would you like me no honestly and we can
make an agreement now so we have it so
for legal reasons that'll be the season
finale do you want me to shoot you in
the back of the head on your 50th
birthday yeah just so you're good
to go i'll go
on your 75th birthday do you want me to
come
and we make the screaming out and i'll
shoot you right in the back of the head
at your birthday party i i i i i i think
so because then i skip all that that's
okay so that's done it's done it's on
film we got it maybe yeah
it's binding it's fine
um yeah no but no we do need to stop
like i just saw this tweet uh because i
was reading an article about the elon
musk's twitter thing and bernie sanders
tweeted we we need to hold the uber rich
accountable for their fair share got it
which i don't know if that's
unreasonable i mean someone's got you
know three people have you know six
seventy percent of the wealth of the
united states i don't know that's
unreasonable and then he tweeted he
responded and tweeted i keep forgetting
you're still alive
but like that is wrong yeah he's he's
that's ageism at its finest like yeah
you know like that doesn't mean that
doesn't make bernie bernie uh i would
say bernie williams yeah
bernie madoff bernie williams shout out
doesn't make bernie sanders voice any
like it's ridiculous that that's just
that's his retort to someone who's
actually you know what i mean like or
someone who's
whatever your views are one is an elder
two he's a respected member of like
congress and stuff and he's trying to do
the right thing and right i know that
he's going after his money but i mean
like it's it is funny that he said that
but it is it isn't but if you compare
him to edison and tesla the ogs
they were actual jerks yeah at least
he's being funny
yeah yeah he's fighting for electric
energy i don't know tesla killed himself
in the new yorker hotel where we used to
film that show guy code and girl code
and there were ghosts of tess the
cameraman's cameras used to turn off
doors used to open there was like this
there's this hallway in the new yorker
hotel where you just walk down into the
door at the end of you just walk down
this long hallway and the door doesn't
open that's so funny really it's weird
and it's all tested it was living there
you made all these like trinkets real
stuff who knows man elon musk might be
tesla by the way by the way there's
there's a there's uh that article that i
sent you there's a way to keep kane
tanaka alive
have you been watching severance
a fictosexual this man married a
hologram bride but now struggles to bond
with her and i was thinking why don't we
become fictosexuals for kane tanaka not
in a sexual way but we bring back kane
tanaka as a hologram i'm sorry he's
sitting next to a hologram right there
that's a hologram that he's married to
that he said he's having it's finding it
very difficult to bond with everything's
fine everything's fine everything's all
good everything's fine yeah spent two
million he uh who was sexually attracted
to fictional characters he spent two
million yen or about 17 300 on the
nuptials but his family didn't attend
which is sad depicted in pop culture as
a 16 year old with turquoise hair
so the i mean i don't love the face
before they had an unofficial wedding
ceremony yeah yeah everything's fine he
spent two million dollars on a hologram
that he was sexually attracted to two
million yen would you guys be okay if uh
we start licensing your likeness to
marry random people what do you mean
like you can marry me as a hologram yeah
i have no problem with that
i have no issues what's the money
it's weird this is the future i see if
you look at their hologram technology
it's getting ready this better not be
the future this better not be the future
future well we won't be around for that
no oh we are around for it well you will
be we're taking you
you want me to come kill you on your
birthday i can do that
that's better than cameo yeah yeah
yeah that that's the new caveat
like
yeah dude you know from for a minute for
a minute
kane was dating the tupac hologram for a
minute yeah for a minute yeah right
after the concert anybody when it was
like a hot the hot [ __ ] kane got in let
me ask you an honest question do you
think in 119 years let's say 100 of
those years being sexually active she
only had sex with one person do you
think that that's possible kate's not
going to have sex with one guy or do you
think kane tanaka
privately was his sex machine what i
choose to believe
what you choose what do you actually
think is the truth
how much how much
dick did
i get
that's the way we end the truth
this has been happening
you asked yourself that question how
much dick did kate did not get oh
oh the humanity a hundred years a dick
a hundred years a dick that's name of my
comedy album is dedicated to paint
tanaka
[Music]
how do i
say goodbye
the good
times that made us laugh
outweigh the bad
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh it's so hard
to say goodbye
to caine